malgré le deuil cruel qui l'a frappé
récemment catherine deneuve a repris son
métier de comédienne une ingénue qui
tombe amoureuse d'un contes libertins
michel piccoli tel est le rôle qu'elle
interprète dans benjamin le film que
réalise actuellement michel deville
pourquoi ces trucs
je ça me plaît
ah non
ils pas des pieds je vous en prie
les bêtises les choses régime m je ne
dis rien
je vous aime
moi je n'ai bertin le sens qu'un
infidèle c'est la première fois que j'ai
vu je sois moi
savez vous que je vous répondrais je me
moque monsieur le comte que vous
m'aimiez moi je ne vous aime pas je
m'ennuie à londres c'est quelle bonne
idée
un château 18e des environs de cognac
sert de cadre aux aventures de benjamin
and la jeune orpheline
catherine deneuve interviendra face à
michel piccoli au milieu des folies d'un
marivaudage tel que les aime michel
deville michel deville qui après martin
soldats retrouve ainsi le climat de ses
premiers films des comédies légères
comme adorable menteuse
oui ça commence comme une comédie légère
impôts libertines c'est tout xviiie
siècle un peu les romans de marivaux
crayon puis tout d'un coup il ya un
personnage qui intervient à ea nous a
surpris comme peut-être il se reprendra
les spectateurs quand on arrive on y ait
du film le film bascule devient plus
grave vient pas dramatique parce que ça
reste une comédie mais ce matin j'ai
tellement peur qu'ils nous à un fait
toni nous mêmes
michèle morgan francine bergé anna gaël
catherine rouvel et jacques dufilho
complètent la distribution de madame
benjamin personnage central du film dans
le rôle est tenu par pierre clémenti je
m'appelle benjamin orpheline bonheur je
suis recueilli dans un merveilleux
château qui appartient à ma tante et là
je rencontrais un conte libertin qui est
l'amant de ma tante et qui se chargera
de faire mon éducation sentimentale qui
laisserais ma impuretés et lui
retrouvera la sienne on vous a vu dans
deux jours on vous a vu dans les ide à
l'enfer vous verra au cinéma lundi
dallas est très très actuel l'a au
contraire vous jouez un rôle décalé j'ai
toujours joué des personnages
agressif et là au contraire c'est un
personnage complètement passifs
complètement qui est soumis aux
événements aux événements qui
l'entourent il est manipulé par les
soubrettes par le comte par la comtesse
et c'est un petit à petit à petit va se
réveiller à la halle avis il va devenir
pire que les autres
quoi